all right thanks everyone for attending
I know this is the last talk of the day
and I appreciate everyone here this is
less product oriented than the others so
I'm going to assume you're all here as
diehard fans of production which is what
I am so this morning we heard from Joe
kava talking about the hardware and data
center side of the Google cloud platform
and I'm here to take you on a whirlwind
tour of how we support the software side
my goal is that you walk out of here
understanding how Google keeps an
infrastructure like this together but
that you also have some ideas that you
can take home to your teams both
organizational and tools at the end I
will stay up here if there are any
questions and I know it's late and
everyone wants to be traffic
I have a set of business cards so if you
just want to grab one and run out and
send me your question I'm happy to
answer it later all righty let's get
going so first a bit about me I joined
Google only a year ago this means I've
actually seen a lot of the places that
you guys are working I've worked in ten
person startups I've worked in hundred
person startups I've worked in a retail
company attempting to reinvent itself
and I also spent almost a decade at
Amazon where I was building internal
tools and automation
if any of you are familiar with AWS code
deploy I designed the internal tool that
that's built on I know baby pictures are
traditional but I figured you would get
a lot more enjoyment out of my 1980s
haircut so here's a picture of me with
Bob Ballard this has not been shown
publicly before enjoy it while you can
alright next I'm going to talk about sre
the what and the why first I want to
tell you a story about cookies everyone
likes cookies so let's start with sis
admin's
what do sis admin's get cookies for sis
amends get cookies when the site stays
up site stays up we get visitors visitor
to give us money yay cookies for
everyone
U is for up time how about developers
what the developers get cookies for
developers get cookies for features
release a new feature
visitors come they give us even more
money yay cookie
before I continue I want to ask you to
go home and put together an experiment
have your developers stop releasing code
for two weeks and let me know what
happens to your site availability maybe
you guys work at a place that has a
production freeze for big business
reports or for holiday stuff and the
fact is that production freeze is
usually result in higher uptime so you
have these two competing priorities your
system means get cookies for keeping the
site up your developers get cookies for
releasing features so these two teams
start to figure things out the system
ins will get more cookies if they could
prevent features from going out and the
developers will get more cookies if they
can figure out a way around this
disturbance rules so devs figure out
they can call it a beta it's just a beta
guys it's okay not a big deal and the
system ins figure out that they can
demand to launch reviews and stretch
those out for really long time if you do
it right developers don't I have an idea
we're going to a percentage flag flip
that's that's a good idea so you end up
with this fighting back and forth and
sadness and no cookies because all your
teams are spending all their time
fighting each other and you get your
conflicts are handled by rules and
process or sorry excuse me you can
increase that egde increased risk chaos
anarchy dogs and cats living together so
what we want is to actually take all of
this women Fiat out of the process have
it handled by individual rules or sorry
handled by rules so teams can have goals
and work together now there actually is
a common solution out there for this dev
and operations problem their conferences
dedicate to dev and operations anyone
have any idea what those are yeah dev
ops so the problem with dev ops I don't
know if you know the story of the blind
men and the elephant but it's a set of
blind men who go and one guy feels the
trunk and it's kind of leathery and
bumpy and that's what he decides the
elephant looks like another one feels
the tusks
long smooth cold that must be what the
elephant looks like another feels the
tail DevOps is a little bit like this it
has a different meanings everywhere you
go different interpretations so is agile
so are various other things so I'm going
to talk about sre possessory actually is
well defined in short this is SRE
there's a two key phrases in this quote
from Ben trainer software engineer and
design and run software engineer is
critical because it turns out services
run better when people who understand
software also understand also run it
they have a deep understanding of what
makes it tick they have a deep
understanding of the interactions and
design and run when actually design your
production environment rather than
having it be a happy accident or
something some dev did well hyped up a
really good coffee right after drinking
you actually have a better environment
there are many many different aspects to
sre I am NOT going to try to discuss all
of them but it's all these activities
that actually make up what we call SRE
so let's say we have a thousand s eries
working on Google's infrastructure
network compute storage etc how many of
them do you guys think are responsible
for cloud maybe 100 of them 10 percent
200 of them I'll give you a hint s3 is
in every office we have around the world
work on cloud it turns out the answer is
that all of our SaaS who support our
infrastructure also support cloud we
don't want to distinguish between what
makes google.com run and what makes
Google cloud platform and therefore your
applications run we don't want to have
communication overhead as the cloud
teams and the internal teams try to
communicate we want to create one
environment that helps everything work
together the rest of my talk is how we
created those teams how we run those
teams and how we do what we do so first
how do we structure SRA from an
organizational perspective how do we
make sure we hire
Deb's into a role focus on production
and keep them happy how do we keep the
team valued inside of Google and how do
we help our teams communicate better and
resolve disagreements with data rather
than assertions or power grabs so first
it's all about leveling the playing
field having common tools having common
knowledge all of our Suri's have to pass
a full softer interview to get hired in
addition to that they have to pass a
non-abstract large system design
interview so in some senses although I
would never tell this to my devs who are
sitting here in the front row whereas
Therese actually have to be more skilled
than our devs are to do the same job you
need to have a greater breadth of skills
does the same software skills the
different domain of application devs are
beholden to product managers they make
features they make you guys happy s
eries are beholding to production
they're beholden to making production as
good as it possibly can be so when both
of these different perspectives
contribute to a design the resulting
design is much stronger here's an
example from an onboarding that a friend
of mine did they evaluated the team
software and they found that there were
a bunch of assumptions was going to fail
in production when we hit scale the devs
had implicitly assumed a particular type
of call would never fail they had
assumed the distribution of the requests
was uniform they'd assume they wouldn't
get hot spotted by users they'd assume
that all of the requests were
average-sized and they failed on the two
tails but that's what our Suri's bring
to the table
then we need to give our Deb's a reason
not to just allow operation to work to
build up because if they're not doing it
why would they care so we do this by
having our devs actually provide the
headcount to sre so if you have a system
that has a really large operational
overhead you don't get as many devs you
don't get to push as many features
because we look at the headcount in
aggregate we also have us every report
to an entirely separate organization
they have their own VP separate from the
dev VP's this gives an authority and
power it allows them to say no when
production me
they need to say no they're not just a
bunch of pager monkeys
there's also scarcity the devs say that
they can donate headcount essary doesn't
have to accept it they can say that's
great but we don't think that service is
actually important enough why don't you
keep supporting it yourself not every
team at Google has s Ari's cloud does
but not every other team and not every
single small service and cloud it's the
important ones so I'll talk a little bit
more about that another slide but the
main point is that s arrays are scarce
the environment very critical so this is
how you actually keep these Devas happy
running in a production team you need to
have at least 50% of your work being
project work so it's not on call that's
not tickets
that's not meetings you actually have to
be doing project work and if there's too
much project work either that gives debs
give more headcount essary
or that extra work actually flows over
into the dev team example project work
for s eries improving the latency of a
service by switching the underlying
database technology writing automation
to speed up deployments and projects
that span services we have a surface
internally that can be queried by other
services because we make robots do
everything for us not Boston Dynamics
type of robots but softer robots so we
have a service you can query internally
that says hey so it's safe to take this
machine down it's a safe to take this
rack down can I take down this data
center that actually syncs with the
state of everything else and gives it
yes or no and that's maintained by
yesiree
and possibly most critically arrestee
teams are a volunteer army there is no
draft not only can you transfer to
another essary team at any time without
your managers permission all of this
applies all devs at Google as well but
you can transfer into dev so if you're
tired of dealing with production you
just really want to sit down with a
product manager and become best friends
you can transfer to dev you don't have
to ask anyone's permission to do it we
actually even have the reverse which is
Mission Control where devs can try
sorry and see if they like it one of my
team says to mission controllers on it
right now really hoping they'll stay if
you're watching this guys we want you to
stay so as a result the teams are fluid
people are coming in and out of the
teams sharing experiences sharing
perspectives and finally we have a
budget this isn't a money budget like
you used to
this is an era budget if I tell you you
have three nines of service availability
I don't want you to go Wow bet I can
push that to three and a half maybe four
nines if I'm really really good you
point one percent era budget go for it
if you want to push out features faster
and make GCP even better do it right up
until you run out of every budget if you
instead would prefer to have poor tests
have your software failing regularly and
have to roll back constantly then you
can choose that too but you'll run out
of every budget much faster and you
actually won't be able to launch and so
these error budgets go in quarterly
cycles now there is an escape valve for
that it's called silver bullets some
teams have literal actual server bullets
and a dev can come up and say I really
really need to push I really really
would like a silver bullet please the s3
will say no problem
you just have to convince the VP that
you actually need to push in that little
ritual which sounds very silly it's
actually very powerful because it puts
it entirely in the hands of the devs
they know they have three silver bullets
and their VP is the one that decides
whether or not it's appropriate to push
this even applies if you have multiple
dev teams working on a service because
era budgets are on a per service basis
not per team so Esther Reed is knocking
in the middle of warring dev teams they
have to work out amongst themselves how
that era budgets going to be spent so we
do have an escape valve if all else
fails there is an irreconcilable dispute
SR ikan off board it's the opposite of
onboarding a dev team basically we've
loved working with you guys
we have irreconcilable differences
kind of like an amicable divorce it's
rare but it has happened
it's a very critical escape valve to
make sure that you don't have teams
festering disagreements for long periods
an example reason for this might be if
you have say a common database at Google
that's encourage for all new acid type
projects we might call it spanner and
new projects are supposed to use it
the devs team says you know spanner is
cool and all we're gonna go build our
own it's very reasonable for the essary
team to say I understand that I disagree
with your reasons and we actually don't
want to support you if you go and build
your own database technology because we
think that's not good for production
s-series are the custodian of production
that the custodian of the customer
experience for google.com and for GCP so
we try to avoid this I mean it's maybe
one or two times over the history of sre
but it has happened and it's not the end
of the world there are teams without
essary teams they'll survive esterase
support their teams in a lot of ways
it's not just about taking pages
although I can assure you that user but
I'm asked very first when I'm
interviewing someone so you guys get
paged s3 support is on a spectrum so we
can go on one end to simply chatting
with the dev consulting with them about
a service doing a little whiteboard
session to full-on producing and design
doc together or in the very extreme yes
actually fully owning a service all the
capacity of the provisioning all of the
pages we don't really think of pages as
the sort of headliner of what sre does
pages are kind of a way of keeping you
honest so the people responsible for
production should take the pages because
that keeps their skin in the game and it
helps keep the essary skill expertise
and perspectives up to date all right
let's talk a little bit about what makes
things go I'd like to talk about the
culture and processes but it's not the
scary pea processes or good processes so
in addition to training and on call
shadowing which you guys probably do it
your companies we like to run
playing game if you will where one
person is the dungeon master and they
have a victim perhaps the class s re
level five lawful neutral alignment
would be my guess I'm or the whole team
and they take turns trying to guess
what's actually going on we run very
complex systems at Google with a lot of
different dependencies so it's rare that
someone other than the dungeon master or
the person running the training session
actually fully knows what the answer is
it's good for our new on callers let
them actually test things out in a
controlled environment some teams
actually even have entire scenarios they
can run where they actually break
something in prod and have the newbies
fix it but it's also good for the
veterans when you have very involved
systems it's good to refresh your
knowledge it's good to figure it oh
that's right that's how that thing works
all right
brief break in the talk for a quiz so
you're on call for Gmail you get a
ticket that says users can see other
users emails what do you do you call
your team lead call your VP call for a
pizza
what do you shut it down I actually ran
the test on this with some non-googlers
most people answer egg the answer is
deep our on callers are fully empowered
to do whatever it takes to protect the
users to protect information to protect
Google and if that means shutting down
Gmail if that means shutting down all of
google.com you that college hire who's
six months out of school who just got
page for your first time are gonna be
supported by your BP by your SVP for
shutting it down and protecting Google
and we actually don't need to worry
about making sure that we troubleshoot
our goal is to restore service
immediately we have records at the
binary state we have logs will
troubleshoot when we're awake when the
devs are in the office when everyone's
actually there we just want to get it
back up and in service now all right
next quiz everyone's still awake
when good software goes bad so you have
a new dev maybe this is another college
hire but on the dev side the new dev
push code broke google.com the entire
search engine for three hours
who's that fault the death quality of
the code reviews lack of tests like a
proper canary process lack of rapid
rollback tools everything except the new
dev the new DEP shows up and write scrap
code that takes down your site it is not
the fault of the dev it's all the gates
between that dev and working prod that
should have stopped him and that's where
you should be looking yes people can
screw up but most of the time human
error
should never have been allowed to
actually propagate beyond the human at
least not as far as prod that brings us
to our probably most critical culture
point of all just blameless post-mortems
studies show that most incidents are
actually caused by human error you heard
Joe say that they've gotten the incident
rate down really far in the data centers
that's awesome
software has not yet including softer
written by you sorry's we still have as
the highest cause human error of one
form or another and it turns out
incidents are best solved you know what
actually happened you know the best way
to not know what happened open every
incident with trying to find someone to
point a finger at because people are
really good they become really good
hiding and making sure there's no trail
and making sure you don't actually know
what happened and you've just made your
job ten times harder 100 times harder a
thousand times harder so avoiding a
blame culture is critical at Google the
general practice is whoever screwed up
right to the post-mortem this avoids
naming and shaming it's gives them the
power to make it right multiple people
contributed which is very common
everyone goes in as honest as possible
put in how you're screwed up we've
actually given bonuses out at All Hands
meetings for taking down the site
because it was someone who owned up
immediately that they did it IRC oh boy
hey
guys rolled it back and they got a bonus
for speaking up and taking care of it so
quickly and in the event of major
outages it's actually not unheard of for
a VP or an SVP to kind of ping someone
to say it's okay
it's okay no one's blaming you we've got
your back
it'll be all right limas doesn't mean
there's not names or details obviously
we need to look into that but it means
we're not picking the people as the
reason things went wrong there shouldn't
be any such thing as an outage that
deserves a firing we have a detailed
post-mortem template that separates out
actions and to prevent detect and
mitigate because we want
defense-in-depth
we don't want to just go yeah well we
did all those things that we needed to
do and now it'll never happen again
because odds are good little happened in
some way maybe you missed something or
it comes in another angle or whatever we
want to guess prevent outages you also
want to detect them faster and want to
mitigate the impact so if something like
this happens again it at least won't
spread as far or lasts as long or affect
as many customers alrighty
in the short time remaining I'd like to
talk a very little bit about how we
actually do our job we really lean
heavily on visualizations but first I
want to talk about the kinds of pages we
like to see as a team pages you know how
to solve or boring make you ask if there
isn't a better way maybe should invent a
robot we invent lots of robots we don't
like being bored we don't want to sit
there dreaming of a better world in
which we aren't paged by boring things
if you can write documentation to fix it
just fix it if you can write down the
step to that clearly you can probably
write the automation if you can't go
write something that lets you write the
automation don't be doing things that
robots can do for you
pages if you're getting recurring pages
stop them from happening so the result
of this is that each page we get this
ideally really new so we don't have
boredom we definitely don't have boredom
this means even our experienced
engineers are probably seeing something
new every single time their pager goes
off this is a fundamental change in
philosophy if nothing is routine and few
incidents are repeated this means you
can't lean as heavily on your previous
experience when debugging the system
means you need much stronger debugging
tools this is not a debugging tool this
is a novice key to view of veridia
messages on my Mac but you get the point
standard debugging like looking for
patterns and log files it doesn't scale
if you don't know what to look for and
with a platform the size of GCP how many
machines logs am I going to look through
until I hopefully find the one that was
failing so we relied very heavily on
various visual tools to help us
troubleshoot unfamiliar problems and
restore service as quickly as possible
graphing tools oh sorry in the next few
slides I will have some open source
tools mentioned I am not advocating
these tools in particular I am NOT
saying we we don't use these tools these
are examples of what we do so you can
use these as a springboard they may be
useful you may use them to find other
tools graphing is a very traditional
form of visualization it's great when
you're looking at a single thing it's
even better when you're looking in
aggregate processes that we care about
at Google there's never just one there's
billions and billions and billions of
them so each of these lines well they
look simple we're actually pulling from
many different sources and getting
aggregated we instrument the heck out of
our binaries because again with a novel
situation you don't always know what
you're looking for
ideally you have a framework that makes
it easy for your developers to actually
export data into your system developers
get bored just like ups people get bored
and they have just as much fun none
writing repetitive monitoring code so
come up with a framework find a
framework whatever he needs that this is
actually simple for your devs to do I
mentioned this before possibly most
critical is that there's actually a huge
amount of storage that we have behind
this solely to store this data because
we
do not want to be troubleshooting in the
middle of an outage an outage is all
about restoring service troubleshooting
is what happens when you're awake
our devs are often engaged in
troubleshooting they have the deeper
knowledge they know where stuff's going
from going on so you need to have this
data historically so you can look at and
not go well we fixed the outage but we
lost all the data that was going to tell
us what was going on in the first place
this helps keep our unusual outages as
short as possible and lets us dig into
what goes on later event graphing is
really really useful for correlating
events take advantage of your human
ability to pattern match it's actually
kind of hard to write robust to do this
although I don't know deepmind self go
so maybe they'll take this away from us
too so this is laying things out by data
center and by time and then the color
and I apologize if that's hard to see
back there the color is actually the
event type this can help you find
patterns that aren't single incidents
like say a software rollout that's
causing cascading failures throughout
the whole stack or a cluster of errors
that's repeating together or if you see
a latency spike and then an error spike
immediately after it and that's repeated
these will all help you get to the root
cause of what's actually going on visual
process tracing I apologize it could not
actually find a lot of truly open source
options for this although there's a
whole bunch of ones you can pay for when
you're looking at performance issues you
sometimes do need to get down to the
process level we have a pretty elaborate
framework that pulls sample queries into
storage and actually does provides a
full trace of them the advantage to
having a tool that allows you do it
visually is you can actually collapse
and expand and compare things a lot
better than if you're looking at a
series of timestamps we're trying to go
okay how how many milliseconds is there
and doing a lot maybe you're better at
math in your head than I am I don't know
I'm not good at it Network flows in
capacity so I work in storage it turns
out that a lot of storage is slow
problems novel not all but many a route
caused in the network
and you can be sitting there staring at
your storage system staring at your
processes and going what the heck and
the problem was way way way far away
from you in the networking team so being
able to quickly see what's the state
what links are overloaded
how many packet errors are you see is a
link entirely down really useful even if
you are not personally responsible for
the network when all else fails yeah
it's all about love files again
unfortunately but what you don't want to
be doing is grepping through these logs
having a system that allows you to have
sequel like queries where you can
actually dig into them more sanely than
trying to come up with the correct
regular expression that will filter out
exactly what you want extremely useful
you want your logs to be easy to consume
easy to understand there's a open source
option there you can also have a Cabana
as a potential of visualization all
right before I end there are two more
things I want to bring to your attention
one is if this interests you we have a
book it's not out yet
it comes out in April and it's actually
getting officially announced at SOE Con
next week but they told me I was allowed
to mention it here this is a sample of
some of the topics this is not at all an
exhaustive list it was written by actual
sres who are doing actual SRA work we
had 70 different contributors 500 years
of Google expertise into it and it's a
it's a crazy thick book I'm really
excited by it
so if this was interesting all of this
has gone into in way more detail along
with some other stuff in the book I
highly recommend it also I don't know
how many of you were able to be in for
the announcement for this but we
actually have gotten one of our tools to
be usable in GCP so stack driver error
reporting excellent tool we would like
to do more of this
we have an extensive ecosystem
internally that we would like to make
available to our cloud customers in fact
we would like it to be available to you
period
that can be challenging it's a little
bit easier forget at least
get available on cloud errors are
grouped and deduplicated by analyzing
their stack traces talked a little bit
about that before and this system knows
about the common frameworks that you use
in your language and groups errors
accordingly so please check it out it's
very cool it's in beta as of I believe
today already we are not doing questions
there we go thank you for your time
today
I made this short so you all can slip
out
you